James just tell us what the atmosphere
is like there yeah the atmosphere
outside after that win has been really
really positive England fans are really
really South African fans here to having
to work but England fans are really
going confidence from that when they now
believe museum was always that heard or
wasn't it that England hadn't previously
overcome under Eddie Jones it was the
bar that was the bar was set that high
with the All Blacks being the best team
in the world they were the favourites to
win this World Cup going for the third
successive World Cup victory so to have
done it and done it as you say so
comfortably yes the score line wasn't
strong in England's favor but the All
Blacks didn't really look like scoring
Lee they got the Tri which was gifted to
them from England if England could have
scored a lot more they could have had a
lot more out there were opportunities
that went big and they were two tries
disallowed so yeah an incredible
performance I think it's fair to say the
best English rugby performance of the
professional era which sounds strange I
know because they of course they won the
World Cup in 2003 but I think just
overall as a performance that was
complete from England
their fans really having to pinch
themselves I'd gather yeah yeah the
belief is there as I say I mean I think
a lot of fans before the game felt
England could win they thought it would
be close but as the game went on and on
you always feel with the All Blacks like
they're gonna come back and a hard time
there was this kind of nervous tension
among England fans because yes England
were leading but of course you know the
All Blacks are going to come back but
just the way they shut them out was very
very impressive it vindicates so many
decisions that Eddie Jones has made not
least a selection in going forward
Farrell combination once again the back
row now looks so complete with curry
Underhill and vana Poehler and you just
feel Momentum's with them of course
let's not get carried away
but everything is going in England's
favor at the moment